-Let's get to the news.
During a cabinet meeting today,
President Trump repeated
his claim that no president
has ever been as tough on Russia
as he has.
And it's true. He was tough.
He even took away
their soccer ball.
"You'll get this back
when you can behave."
[ Laughter ]
According to "Vanity Fair,"
White House Chief of Staff
John Kelly was irate with
President Trump's comments
at his press conference
with Vladimir Putin.
Okay, that's fair.
But also when isn't
this guy irate?
[ Laughter ]
Every photo of John Kelly looks
like he just found out this play
has another 45 minutes.
[ Laughter ]
President Trump attacked his
critics this morning tweeting,
"Some people hate the fact
that I got along well with
President Putin of Russia.
They would rather go to war
than see this.
It's called
Trump Derangement Syndrome."
Hey, man, just a tip --
maybe don't name a derangement
syndrome after yourself.
The guy who discovered syphilis
didn't name it Steve's disease.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Oh, I got Steve's."
According to a new poll, 73% of
Democrats want a fresh face
to be their presidential nominee
in 2020.
And as soon as he heard this,
Bernie went for the Botox.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right, 73% of Democrats
want a fresh face to be their
presidential nominee in 2020.
Coincidentally, fresh face is
what Stephen Miller
had for dinner last night.
[ Laughter ]
"Are you sure it's fresh?"
"I like to eat the smile first."
[ Laughter ]
President Trump
suggested last night
that he may not protect
Montenegro
under NATO's mutual defense
pact.
In fact, he doesn't even like
to say Montenegro
because he thinks
that's why Papa John got fired.
[ Laughter ]
During President Trump's visit
to the U.K.,
Queen Elizabeth
reportedly wore a brooch
given to her
by former President Obama.
Wow!
Usually --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got to say.
Usually it's only her hats
that throw that much shade.
[ Laughter ]
The House released a spending
bill today that sets aside
$5 billion to build President
Trump's proposed border wall.
Ugh, can we just tell him
we built it and move on?
It's not like he's gonna go down
and check.
He knows there are
Hispanic people there.
Like, let's just do
a Google search
for "Great Wall of China,"
throw some gold letters on it
and tell him it came in
under budget.
Boom, there you go. We never
have to talk about it again.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally,
according to a new study,
men who drink four to seven
servings of alcohol per week
are more fertile
than men who do not drink.
They're calling this study
Irish people.